s'il pose après nos deux pays c'est
l'exécution de la peine et contrairement
à ce qu'on veut nous faire croire
aujourd'hui
l'antagonisme il n'est pas entre les
policiers et les magistrats pendant 25
ans j'étais la police judiciaire pendant
25 ans tous les jours j'ai travaillé
avec des magistrats
il est entre une certaine idée de la
sécurité disons de droite et une
certaine insécurité disons de gauche
pour un certain nombre de personnel
politique
je pense au garde des sceaux mais je
pense surtout à ses prédécesseurs alan
tenir à madame b to b
finalement la sanction c'est un gros mot
et la prison c'est le mal eric c'est
comme si c'est quelque chose que je ne
partage c'est un homme de gauche
et pour vous il est il a la même
politique que christiane taubira oui le
jeune garde des sceaux oui je pense que
il fait tout aujourd'hui pour faire en
sorte le yen ou de moins en moins de
personnes incarcérées d'avoir je suis
parent je suis pas un fanatique de la
prison à tout crin je suis persuadé que
si on veut faire baisser la délinquance
et la violence de notre pays il faut une
réponse systématique rapide effet les
moyens je pense que ce que souhaite le
président république c'est
l'anéantissement la droite républicaine
comme d'ailleurs la gauche républicaine
c'est une stratégie qui me paraît
extrêmement dangereuse c'est moi ou le
chaos
et finalement une démocratie c'est quoi
céder ce sont des gens qui n'ont pas les
mêmes idées
et puis il ya un vote et après il ya une
politique différente réduire démocratie
au parti unique voulue un petit peu en
marché devrait être le parti unique et
fasse en marche n'y aurait que les
révolutionnaires les fous les extrêmes
ça me paraît quelque chose qui est
dangereux le la droite républicaine a
toute sa place dans la vie politique
française